so lopez going through his final warm-up
tosses here and ronaldo lopez making
the start number one here on the 2020
baseball season
tim at shortstop got handcuffed by it
does he have enough time the answer is
no
very close play at first base i thought
he beat him watch i thought he got him
too and i i don't know if you want to
review it this early but i think he's
out in fact he's out by a pretty good
margin yeah out good call josh donaldson
already was down the stairs now nelson
cruz the 1-1 pitch is swinging out line
drive fair inside third down the left
field line it's going to bounce off the
sidewall polanco is going to make third
and he will stop there
on a nelson cruz double
and cave will have a chance again here
in the first inning and the 1-0 game of
the year deep to left backing up now is
jimenez still tracking back at the wall
he'll reach up it's gone grand slam for
jake cave
picking out a fastball and hitting it
over the wall and left elo jimenez
crashed into the bullpen gate out there
and he is now down on the warning track
so eloy out there in left field walking
off the contact against the wall
it looks like he's going to stay in the
ball game
up and out
and that is ball three so three balls
and two strikes and now a meeting at the
mound wants to see if he's okay i'm
pretty sure that's one of the reasons
grundle looked into the dugout that's it
for ronaldo lopez
39 pitches three balls and two strikes
on the eight hitter for the twins and so
the sox are going to go into the bullpen
very early and gio gonzalez who was
brought over as pretty much of an
insurance policy which the sox have had
to cash in early here it comes
swing and a miss strike three inning
over as kentucky is set for his twins
debut three two pitch swinging a miss he
got him on a slide cruise cracked a
double to help open up the first inning
to the right field corner and down for a
hit avila will score
donaldson behind him polanco flying
around third it's a bases clearing
double
for nelson cruz what a great piece of
hitting right here he stays on this ball
he wasn't sure if geo was going to throw
him something soft right there so he
lets the ball travel understands that
his fastball can't beat him here's
rosario the ball dumped into short left
and that ball carrying to the gap
and cruz around third he's going to
score and the twins have scored four
here again in the second inning they're
going to check out alloy jimenez out
there in left field again so eloy who
ran into the wall on the grand slam in
the first inning
maybe he's saying he's a little dizzy
still and he's not quite seeing the
baseball clearly
yeah there's going to be a change now
will come out of the ball game here in
the second inning now louise hit eyes
as he smacks one to left near the line
del monaco won't get this one that's a
base hit here comes eddie rounding third
he will score stopping at second base
his cave it's a nine nothing game but
eyes is two for two almighty to now
stink to a nine-nothing lead
struck him out on a changeup
here is encarnacion and the o2 pitch is
on the outside corner strike three calls
miata not messing around fastball three
strikeouts back to back punch outs from
tenta two down nine nothing twins kenta
mayed has given up just one hit through
two innings
called strike three maeda with a slider
for his fourth strikeout that one had
the whole plate and even though danny
mendick thought it was out of the zone
it was not
nelson cruz against geo gonzalez and
cruz goes down to get it and mashes
for the third straight game in the
series
somebody's got 10.
that ties a major league record for any
series between teams in major league
baseball
ever and we are three games in for the
2020 season the lead continues to mount
mia continues to pitch well with the
lead
and a 92 on our sinker down and in and a
swing and a miss by a bray who picks up
strikeout number five two out base
runner for edwin encarnacion yeah the
swing of the miss
she's something down and away good pitch
strikeout number six for
maeda is
high drive center field going back
is the center fielder to the warning
track to the wall jump goodbye baseball
a two-run home run off of the bat of
louise robert his first big league home
run
find that baseball and hand it to number
88 bring him home for the first time
as a white sox player
luis robert drills one
for the first time it's a slider that
instead of being on the outside corner
kind of drifted back middle in five very
good innings
and kenta maeda's twins debut nelson
cruz is the batter and the pitch is
swinging a rocket to left deep down the
line towards the corner back and gone
nelson cruz just owns the white sox as a
twin he has four hits today
two home runs he has knocked in seven
runs against the white sox today he's
never gonna want to leave chicago i mean
this guy is absolutely unbelievable four
extra base hits today
he's picked up right where he left off
last season so here is marwyn gonzalez
gonzalez lifts one high and deep to
right and that one is gone very quickly
too
gonzalez with his first home run his
second hit of the afternoon and marwyn
gonzalez makes it two touchdowns for the
twins it's now 14-2 anderson over four
on the day strike three call ball game
over and the twins clobber the white sox
14-2 and begin the year by taking two
out of three in chicago